[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time i'm rhett and i'm
link this week at the round table of dim
lighting we're going on a first date in
the past in our minds
we ask you what's your worst or wildest
first date story could be your first
date of all time first date with your
future partner a blind date etc your
story might be featured in a future ear
biscuits episode well i got news for you
some of them about to be featured but
first we're going to tell our own
biscuits episode this is it right the
future is here yep
yep it's now um
and i got it i got some thoughts about
first dates and in our experiences
in general
but um
you know they're probably starting with
our own experience there are probably
some podcast hosts out there
um who could fill up an entire
episode of a podcast maybe even
do a whole podcast just based on their
own first date stories yeah not these
two boys yeah and i i
i think my story
will shed some light on why that is for
us but um
yeah what was your first date well
i'll i'll i'll wait jesse first i'll
wait until you i'm gonna tell i'm gonna
just briefly tell the story of my first
date with jesse but i'll wait until
you've told your story and we're talking
about why we d we didn't have a lot of
first dates
uh because i think it's multifaceted
yeah um
i probably told this story before i and
you know you probably don't even hear
that disclaimer but i'm going to say it
anyway um
you know jesse and i our relationship
started sort of before it was official
because when i met her i was in college
and she was a senior in high school i
love making you retell this story just
so you have to tell that and let me just
say uh
one of the things i've noticed and i
think this is a good development in uh
in society but like
one of
one of the things that i've noticed
about just our kids coming up and the
things that they say about the age
discrepancy and and dating relationships
now is
the sort of the rule that everybody
throws around is you don't date anybody
that's not either in your grade or a
grade that touches your grade
so one year apart
whereas when we were coming up it was
incredibly common
i'm not defending this i'm just saying
it was incredibly common for like
seniors to date freshmen it was just
like it was pretty much the norm 25
years ago i mean i dated a sophomore as
a senior oh there you go
guilty
guilty as charge does that junior gap
there um
so i think this is a good cultural
evolution that uh that's not happening
as much anymore and now but for me
you know i always think i was 19 and
jesse was uh 17 when we met
and
she was about to turn 18
just to clarify but we didn't date we
did not date i just liked her when i
found out she was in high school i was
like i can't date a girl in high school
even if she is 18
i'm not gonna date a girl who's in high
school she turned 18 in december of that
senior year
um
but we continued to talk and we
continued to see each other at church
again i had met her at church in the
first place and our families were
friends it was so hot and so it was i
mean
there is something about meeting someone
at church that is super hot just so you
understand because it's like a taboo to
it yeah meeting somebody at a bar is
like okay yeah we're drinking we're
talking we're there because we're we
think that there might be an eventual
sexual connection with some chemistry
no i'm saying that's never happened to
you or me well but i'm i've watched
movies okay yeah yeah so based on the
movies
uh yeah yeah but i'm saying that that
scene is people don't go to church
that's not in a lot of wrong times for
the uh
potential
you know
connections in that way but people
unless you're right but the thing but
the thing is is
actually a lot of people are yeah oh
yeah the purpose of churches were there
to focus on god
but in reality at a certain age you're
there to focus on the opportunities
so
but again we did not date and christian
mingle irl we didn't date
at all
while she was a senior even though she
would say that we went on some things
that definitely seemed like dates
the first official date
was when she was a freshman in college
and
and i was like okay i'm gonna i'm gonna
really whine and dine this girl
i'm gonna take her to outback
and you're also not gonna drink any wine
of course not back baby but this is the
thing i mean that's exotic i didn't i
wasn't taking this whole other continent
i wasn't taking her to outback
ironically
no
outback was the nicest restaurant i
could even
think of to take her to
i'm not i'm not joking you don't
understand where we come from
out back was the nicest restaurant i
could think of
yeah now there were other restaurants
like in raleigh the seats don't even
have cushions they're like wooden booths
it's f it's very rustic it's it's uh
it's all i knew of australia for my mind
there was a spectrum of restaurants
at one end you had fast food like
mcdonald's not gonna take a girl to
mcdonald's
in the middle you had
applebee's
yeah like that would be like applebee's
is a nice restaurant first of all just
in my mind applebee's is a nice
restaurant it's but it's more of the
decor kind of makes it more of a party
atmosphere yeah it's a neighborhood bar
and grip but then the end of the
spectrum the absolute nicest restaurant
i could conceive of was the outback
because they searched stakes and it was
and it was kind of pricey you might have
to pay like 16.99 yeah for for your own
meal just for one
i definitely remember thinking like
i can
i can go out on a date
and and spend twenty dollars if i do it
right
and i was thinking with a tip i might
with a tip and a blooming onion we may
be getting out of here for 49.
yeah that's yeah that's fancy and that
would wipe me out for a long time oh
yeah oh yeah
yeah so you have to worry about gas
money after that now
my wife
uh
comes from a pretty well-off family and
outback was not her idea of a nice
restaurant but she didn't care she
really liked me and she never would have
said anything about it she didn't think
anything of it at the time really
it was only later that she was like yeah
there's like a lot
cooler like not you know non-chain
places like i didn't understand that
restaurants
weren't chains
i was like oh this is oh there's only
one of these
there must be not doing something right
if you can't franchise this across the
world
yeah then you're not doing something
right
yeah
so this these are the things i remember
i remember
not really what it was like inside the
outback i don't remember what i ordered
well i i think we know though yeah but
you can imagine like 1990
kind of the same as now in and out back
probably 99 98.99 i don't think they've
changed in there um
and first of all i still like the
outback oh yeah
it's a solid meal every time
but
i had a pair of i had to think you know
i had a thing that i would do
i'll go into lots of characters
just in general at that time in my life
which is a thing that i would do i don't
know why i don't necessarily do that
anymore but also not with not amongst
your friends like i don't remember you
know that being a thing we would all do
this
like put on a pair of glasses and start
using a different voice yeah yeah it was
very common amongst i mean definitely
like making videos but
um if there wasn't a video camera
involved i guess we would still goof no
but no but i think about um
like campus crusade and i definitely
think about summer project like
i don't know how you behaved on summer
project but i saw a summer project i
first thought yes i was there to share
the gospel bring people to a saving
knowledge of jesus christ and i did my
part there okay
um
but
i was also
i took every opportunity to like get up
in front of everybody and emcee whatever
there was sure right and so i i remember
coming back from
uh slovak i was coming back from
slovakia and i had spent the whole year
the whole summer in slovakia like being
other people we were doing these english
camps and it's like we had wigs and
glasses and we had all these characters
i just loved that kind of crazy american
it was i mean a slovak audience is a
great audience by the way i don't know
if that's still the case but
there's ever a group of slovaks that
want to watch me do comedy alone
it's probably not then i i'm i'm ready
for that because i'm killed with slovak
crowds
now
i had a pair of glasses
some of those like amber vision
probably the same ones that we ended up
using for uh
like walter
sub check we ended up using them for the
redneck characters yeah
yeah you would put those on
the they read the suns are you telling
me you took uh costume glasses on your
first date with jessie no no this is a
spur of the moment i had these costume
glasses in my car at all times okay on
the ready i didn't know if i needed to
in case in case a slovak pedestrian
walks in front of the car uh amber
vision glasses and these weren't
technically amber vision but amber
vision glasses those yellow tender
glasses are great if you need to like
spot a deer
in the sun
um which i've never done
but i thought that maybe an opportunity
would present itself so i just had him
in my car
so she's she's coming to the uh she's
i don't remember all the details but
she's walking through the car and i
guess i had my son i must have preempted
i must have planned this because i had
my glasses i took them out and i put
them on
and i walked up her up to her and i said
excuse me ma'am
where are you headed and i and i was
acting like i was a cop who was
interrogating her
now that's not that's not top glasses
again it not really but you know
it was it was clear what i was doing it
was flirt also uh this was at a time
impersonating a police officer wasn't as
controversial as it would be now you
know what i'm saying like
i mean i'm not going to get into that
whole thing but like
acting like a cop now it just has just a
different vibe than it did 25 years ago
so
amber vision glasses
make you a cop not
uh my friend yeah well
no but if you think about no actually
that's not true if you think about a cop
that has aviators like a hat like a like
a police hat and like aviators on
that's actually kind of like a 1980s
yeah but these aren't aviators these are
no they're aviators that have ant that
are amber vision so they're amber
they're shaped like aviators but they're
not mirrored if it was mirrored glasses
then it would have been perfect but i
didn't have those i just had yellow
tinted ones so what so this is all
spur of the moment what was her response
she
was
i put her in this weird position because
she talked she's told me this sense that
she was like
she was uncomfortable because i was like
interrogating her but no oh you didn't
let up no but she was sort of mesmerized
and intrigued by this choice that i was
making now she had already like seen me
do my comedy thing like in front of crew
and that
and she and she says that one of the
first times that she realized that
this may be
this guy may be the one was when i was
dancing down the aisle at one of those
meetings but
so
she
appreciated this and also she didn't i
she it was obviously very flirty it was
the most direct flirting that i had done
because i've been saying handcuffs i've
been saving up you know i've been the
good boy who wasn't going to be dating
and we might hang out but i'm not going
to flirt with you i'm not going to open
your door for you i'm not going to pay
for your meal i'm not going to do
anything that signals that i want to
date you
but i've been thinking about this all
summer
when she comes back
when i get back
into town i'm gonna date her and i'm
gonna take on a real day and i'm gonna
open the door for her i'm gonna pay for
a meal i'm gonna impersonate a cop no
rules just right and um
again i wish i had a script of the
things i said but it definitely worked
in my favor there was there you wrote
you wrote a script huh no it was you
know i'm saying i i came up with it in
the moment and i'm sure it was
impressive and very funny and
um to her only to her well but she was
the audience
yeah well i mean you had practiced on
slovaks
yeah i mean in a pre-internet age now
we're all the same now because of the
internet but like crazy american going
over there it's more about you than this
but she i don't mean to throw slovak the
thing that she uh that she said is that
she hadn't you know she
unlike me she had been on a lot of first
dates
jesse had been on a lot of first dates
yeah and uh
but she
hadn't and if you see pictures of me at
the time i mean there wasn't uh you know
it's not a lot of things very physically
impressive about
the specimen that i was at the time
um but i was but i was really relying on
my wit and my willingness to just do
something unexpected and outside of the
box good you went for it and she really
appreciated it
and um i don't know if we ever went
about that back to outback but i kept
those glasses in my car for a very long
time
we still have them here by the way i
believe yeah i think we still they might
be at the creative house on that shelf
now it's probably the same huh
because we lost the lens out of it the
glasses that maybe i found it allowed me
to
marry my wife huh
so that's that's that's your first day
that's all i can remember but then it
was very quickly
second date
third date
now we're dating now we're an item later
we were engaged yeah event uh well how
how long did you date before you got
engaged
one year
one year okay christy and i dated for
a year and a half
yeah
okay we move quick i'll share my first
date story
but first we want to remind you that
trevor
has a podcast
we've blessed it
trevor talks too much it's out there
uh he's doing it every week
if you haven't checked it out you should
totally check it out he's got all types
of guests that
i don't know who they are i don't know
who baby ariel is i don't know who
larae i've heard of both of these people
but it's that's the great thing about it
is you get introduced
but i have heard of two people
in the entertainment space
of the younger generation than me
it's like oh we got trevor
he's going to talk to these people i
don't know about and i'm going to be
exposed to it
expose yourself to the younger
generation through trevor's podcast you
got to work on yours it's the only way
to do it on your pitch trevor talks too
much there's also a youtube channel of
the song i'm going to say trevor is a
natural you know yeah he's doing great
it's so proud of it it wasn't like we
heard him doing like podcast
impersonations
as he was walking down the hallways of
mythical entertainment i've never seen
him wear uh
headphones even shooting glasses
um
but he and it's not an easy thing to do
just let me say it's not an easy thing
oh this is just sit down and this is so
hard no this is easy talk is talking to
your best friend every week is easy but
there was a time in which we talked not
really people that we that we
uh did not know
and got to know them over the course of
an hour and like had an interesting
conversation with them an easy thing
it's like a first date
every episode of trevor toss too much is
a first friend date with somebody and
you know they can go sideways just as
much as a as a blind date could you know
because that's basically what it is it's
set up you know someone from
their
internet personality and then you're
gonna have a conversation with them you
don't know what they're gonna bring but
it's up to you to make it work
see if he does it yeah he's good at it
watch it listen to it trevor talks too
much
i told christy last night
i'm gonna talk about we're gonna talk
about first dates what do you remember
about our first date
um
and she was like well we went you know
we went to chili's i'm like yeah we went
to chile oh nice that's a nice there's
no outback but it's it it's a close
second it it is lower than the outback
but just a little bit so it's i could
probably i anticipated that i could
probably afford dessert
you know
and then the bowling that we were gonna
go on afterwards the bowling that you
were gonna go on we're gonna go on we're
gonna go out for what is it i don't know
what the verb is we're going to bowl we
were going to the bowling we were going
we were going to do
afterwards
um
yeah so chili's is nice for a first date
um
when you want to keep it super casual
especially when you're very fixated
on
not building things up too much and
really taking it slow you know
as i've established i feel like you're
projecting though i feel like the
current link is projecting on the former
link when you pick chili's you weren't
thinking about taking it slow you were
thinking this is about as nice as i can
do okay
but that may be true
the other thing that is true is that
from a relationship starting
dating
again
i was you know i was coming off my high
school relationship that was like it it
got way too
involved
in
in ways that i've talked about it was it
was uh it was an aggressive relationship
that like it was a lot of guilt
so like i wanted to change
in
how i did things i wanted to be very
super christian in my in my dating
relationships i wanted to be very
calculated
that probably didn't extend to my
decision to take her to chili's
but as she reminded me it did extend to
like how i asked her on the date
i was like
you want to hang out
this is what she remembers
and because i asked her last night i was
like
do you do you remember what you
ordered she was like caesar salad
because i had already eaten dinner
because when you asked me out on what
you thought was a date the way that you
did it hey you want to hang out
i didn't even realize that you were
asking me out on a bonafide date
it's like you played it so nonchalant
and of course i'm so much in my head
that all of this was calculated i was
like
i don't want i don't want to build this
up too much
like that's the interesting thing about
link is that he'll be doing something
that seems very haphazard and misguided
and ill-informed but he's actually
really thought about it
yeah i'm i'm thinking of like that's
linking the nutshells of it yeah
and it actually the overthinking of it
is what fuels the chaotic
nature of the the outward vibe
i think
so it's even you have no clue what's
going on in here when you see what's
happening out here
you know it's like this guy's just
flying by the seat of his pants it's
like he's skydiving ah
but no it's like i'm driving the plane
but i'm driving it into the mountain
yeah definitely it's the plane's engine
is has
stalled
it's hot it's running hot man
uh so yeah she ordered a caesar salad
because as we get to chili's she's like
it's dawning on her that she's on a date
with me
yeah and she's like well [ __ ] i've
already eaten so
what am i gonna do if she didn't tell me
she didn't tell me for months
she may have never told me until last
night no i she told me
definitely we talked about it
years ago but i don't know when she
actually
first told me
it was well into our relationship when
she first told me it had to be that like
i was i blindsided her with the first
date
uh
we go to chili's
it went went well
um
i don't remember
too much about it impersonations i
didn't do any impersonations no no
glasses no glasses i didn't well no wigs
i wasn't i didn't wear glasses at the
time i was not wearing a wig no
opportunity i i do remember that
i had a lot of questions
for her like
topic starters
you know i i wanted to really make it
conversational and be very inquisitive i
don't remember any of the specific
questions but
that was
that was my approach it's like okay
we're gonna be
we're gonna be sitting here at chili's
what the crap i gotta have things to ask
her
it's like you know cause you're like
what if it doesn't go well like i'm
accessing all this anxiety from like my
first girlfriend it's like when i call
her on the phone i gotta write down the
things i'm gonna talk about right like
there there had to have been a little
bit of that like in retrospect it was
like oh we hit it off and it was
wonderful but like the expectation of
that i think it was having a bunch of
conversation starters
was was
like my
comfort blanket
then we went like you could have one
superpower what would it be a security
blanket
uh i don't think they were that cheesy
that wasn't that cheesy 25 years ago
yeah the people you asked that question
in fact i asked that question to jesse
on that bench outside of macaroni grill
when we first talked to each other i bet
you it was okay yes and she and she says
as cheesy as it sounds now at the time
when you asked that question
it was kind of like oh he's asking
interesting questions now i wouldn't ask
that question now right but at the time
it was it was something that we did we
like to talk about ideas and we like to
you know we like to explore things
beyond just like
just the getting to know you stuff but
and she remembers when we went bowling
and went on hillsboro street to that
like the bowling alley where we had both
taken class bowling club
bowling for pe 486
where we learned how to ball
um
remember the class number we weren't in
it together
i had to i had to go and learn how to
bowl at like
7 50 in the morning that's a strange
time to learn how to bowl yeah you're
not loosened up or anything yeah
and a lot of it was devoted to like how
do you keep score manually this is a
skill that i i think would come back to
me if i ever need if i'm ever like in
like a rustic environment where we want
to set up like post-apocalyptic bowling
yeah when there's no electricity i know
how to register a turkey you know what
i'm saying yeah not that i would ever
bowl a turkey i never got that good but
she did remember that my form was very
impressive
and of course you want to take a girl
bowling because
you can talk to her you know and then
when she bowls you can look at her ass
let's be real
and she can also look at your ass
and i i was real swanky about it i would
throw that right leg
back
behind my
left
ankle
and i just i just felt like i was just
just
snapping it you know well if you got
amber vision glasses on while bowling i
didn't uh you can not only see the pins
but you can also see the ass even better
oh yeah
it's like higher costs
across a field
um
she was she was very preppy dresser i
was like this like 90s alternative big
jinko pants and like
i'm surprised you could even bowl in the
jeans you were wearing no it's like you
could literally hide three bowling balls
up each pipe pant leg
bleach blonde hair spiked up
uh thrift store
shirts
that smelled funny even after you washed
them a bunch
that was both of our styles
um
bowling was good we didn't want the date
to end and we so we went and got some
coffee and we talked about
her ring
that
she still has that i said
it was like a sterling ring with like
this blue ball on top of it a sterling
ball and i was like you know your ring
looks like planet hollywood you know
that restaurant
in myrtle beach that like arnold
schwarzenegger and rambo started
i'd never been there but she was really
impressed she like remembers that you
thought my ring looked like the
restaurant planet hollywood
what a redneck
and you know what it didn't matter she
talked about the uh
scholarship competitions that she was in
which
i just thought were beauty pageants
scholarship competition yeah there was i
think that's how they made you feel
better about uh
you know
i
i don't know if she was if there's a
swim where division but she got a
scholarship okay
so whatever
we talked about that
she remembered that and that was it our
next date
was
uh
like a few weeks later but it timed out
with valentine's day and because i
didn't want to send this message
that like oh this is getting serious i
made it a group date
but she didn't know it was a date
but i invited other friends
to go
who
i think the people from our inner
varsity
um
bible not other couples yeah it was all
it was it was a couple other couples
i don't remember who it was that's what
she remembers it's weird yeah the whole
thing was weird and it was
so it was you know it it it all happened
within the context of
this like what's the right way to date
that pleases god and you know that i
don't fall back into like
a
very quickly moving into a physical
relationship and stuff like that oh yeah
i was like and i thought we were both
really thinking about it i don't know if
it was as calculated as
as we project back on ourselves
you're a very calculated person but we
were also in the midst of a culture that
this is just the way that you did things
so you weren't an exception everyone
every guy who was taking
this environment very seriously and was
in leadership and was leading a bible
study or was leading worship or was him
seeing like we were very involved
yeah there was an expectation that
number one you were only gonna date
christian girls and most likely you were
only gonna date girls that were within
the same ministry that you were in you
weren't like we weren't looking for iv
girls or navigators girls we were
looking for campus crusade girls because
that was the ones that we were all in
our family and for the people who didn't
and the guys who would like date
somebody and date somebody else it's
like you just you just judged them
exactly that's what i'm saying so it
wasn't like i'm not saying you weren't
pious
we both were
but the way you're talking about it is i
wanted to make sure that i did
everything right and it's just like well
we all did i i've never been the kind of
person that evaluated every decision
that i'm making the same way that you do
yeah but i still was behaving in the
same way because of the
environment that we were in and the
expectations yes it was double whammy
for me but yeah it's the fact that you
were somebody if you were to go through
the same thing oh i'm just dating some
girl from my psychology class
all of a sudden you would have 12 guys
you had to answer to well what do you
mean you're dating a girl from your
psychology class i think we sometimes we
fail to remember just how
i want to i'm going to use the term
cult-like uh you know i don't think the
campus crusade is a cult
but there are cult-like qualities to any
sort of group that is centered around
ideology and expectation like that
because it's just like oh you you're
doing that well
are you are you doing it the way that we
want you to do it are you doing because
we're holding you accountable the way
you're doing it yeah we were zealous it
was even a little bit the fact that i
was dating a girl
from carolina
you know but she was involved in campus
crusade yep um
i mean there was questions about that
you know
but but and this is what contributed to
the fact that like we never experienced
dating because like you know i had this
serious girlfriend
in my senior year and
freshman year in college
and then we broke up and then sophomore
year i was like i'm not dating anybody
i'm gonna figure out what i'm gonna how
i'm gonna
move forward
with a plan
and i like i like subscribing in this
system
you know there was this i kissed dating
goodbye thing that was the that joshua
harris book came out i did not read it
but it pervaded our culture
of well dating is not just something you
do for the fun of it dating is something
you
you replace with
a more rigorous
assessment
that then is all about like finding them
finding a partner finding a life partner
getting married but the thing that both
of us did and i'm sure many other guys
did
being someone who didn't also didn't
read the book but all but knew the
principles
what we ended up doing
our application of kissing dating
goodbye
ended up putting in in this place where
we were dating but we were dating
without communicating that we were
dating and we were dating in very
purposely non-romantic ways
it was just so weird and misguided you
end up eating two dinners because you
don't know what the hell he's talking
about and it wasn't again i don't want
to blame the i mean it was we were
victims of the culture and the way but
it was also we were just we just didn't
know what we were doing and we were
misapplying even even that principle we
were because that whole the point of the
i kids dating goodbye which i don't
agree with and joshua harris obviously
doesn't agree with it at this point
was that don't date but you you do
something that's more intentional and
you court someone right and it's a much
more intentional calculated thing
i don't agree with that either but the
point i'm making is that we were so
misguided that
we just ended up saying you want to hang
out
like i'm thinking that i like you and
i'm thinking that i'm attracted to you
and i'm thinking that i want to look at
your ass while you're bowling yeah but
i'm not none of that's coming out in the
in any of the actions that i'm taking
there was a point where you would
we made a big deal about the dtr
defining the relationship where you do
communicate very exp not explicitly well
in explicit not in explicit terms but in
no uncertain terms
like i'm interested in you i want to
date you i want this to be our status
i i want this to be exclusive
and then i would go on and say
i'm not going to tell you that i love
you unless i'm going to marry you so i'm
never going to say that unless we're
getting engaged and we're not going to
kiss and we're not going to have a
physical relationship so you would
define all of a sudden it would go from
like this confusing thing to this like
ultra over defined thing but the thing
that we totally missed and what i'd like
to focus on is just
we missed
dating the dating experience and yeah
all right so our pendulum song way over
here to be like very safe you can
absolutely
and this was our idea that like you want
to protect from the pendulum swing in
the other direction where you
date nonchalantly and willy-nilly and
you're just stepping on people's hearts
and having your heart stepped on and
maybe even worse maybe you get an std or
an un unplanned pregnancy or you know
it's like so it's like if you're gonna
err on one side let's err on the god
side of safety and it so
that was very appealing
um but yeah and in retrospect i feel
like i missed out on this whole thing
which is part of why i'm putting this
prompt out here this like tell me about
your like crazy first dates because like
all we have to go on are movies
you know and the stories of others
um
i just feel like
the
that first date with christy
was really the only
like
semi adult like moving into adulthood
dating experience i ever had because
high school you know that's different
you know it's like you're in this
self-contained this closed ecosystem
where everybody knows everybody
especially in our high school and in our
county
it was like well
if you if you're interested in somebody
they're probably dating somebody else so
you got to wait your turn
and then you got to jockey for position
and then
you can't just go from dating somebody
to the next person to the next person
because kind of like our crusade
experience it was like everybody would
judge you as like
you just you're just dating trying to
date everybody and even then there
wasn't a lot of like first dates it was
like oh no
the football games on friday night i'm
gonna sit with you at the pizza hut
afterwards right
because we're boyfriend and girls you
were kids and then you start to pretend
to be adults in college
and you can go out on a date and you can
you know yeah so the thing we never had
which most of the stories we're going to
get into
they seem to be like okay i'm either in
college or i'm a single
young adult
and i'm actually
dating somebody meeting somebody for the
first time for a date whether it's
online dating or whatever like that we
missed that whole boat because the
relationships that we were in
when we graduated college were with
jesse and christy who we are still
dating we're
now married to yeah for over 20 years
yeah so that we just have these
experiences today tonight is my date
night
it's going to be a double date but uh
with some friends from other people
other friends ivy friends other friends
yeah uh old old uh work work buddy who
came into town
let's read these go for rachel rachel
simone
first date to a comedy club we were two
of six people in the audience oh that's
awkward one of the comedians out of
jokes asked me where i was from and when
i said russia he said i knew it you have
a potato face
my date become boyfriend
called me potato face for two years
after that
i thought that would be an irish thing
okay
yeah not a i was a russian and potato
face i don't understand i'm not gonna
try to explain that because i don't well
i don't know well this is just this
community it doesn't make i don't i
don't think this is like a known thing
that russian people have potato faces i
think this is just a bad comedian's
you know she seemed to joke take the
joke well though if if her
if her boyfriend
if she endured her boyfriend calling her
that i i don't think it was that
mean-spirited it was like
a good-hearted
ribbing well what do you you know what
puts him in a weird position one of the
things one of the ways i'm evaluating
these things
is
imagining if i were to
be in the position to date at this point
in my life
with going to a comedy club would this
be on the top 10 things that i might
choose to do on a first date i would
unless it was somebody who was like if
it's a hot ticket
yes
but just the six i'll be terrified of
this because
yeah i mean
i've actually only been to a comedy club
uh i think maybe twice i've been to a
handful of times i've been charlie good
night's back in raleigh and i never did
that i don't think i went i went one
time with my dad like there was this
comedian who would come on jumbo and
billy i can't even remember who it was
the morning show and of course me and my
dad were both fans of of them
eventually got to go on the show and i
took my dad because he was such a big
fan but we went to the was it the laugh
factory out here went to laugh factory
there but when we when we were there
uh me and my dad went it was we were
both fans of this guy kinda
that was fun i'd love to get
going with my dad is a good idea out
here at the laugh factory we went way
too early wasn't anybody there and it
was awkward i think that this is uh you
know again and i was scared that i was
gonna get called out or like
like i'm afraid of the magicians gonna
call on me well and that's like a
meeting that happened to the laugh
factory just i mean when you're a tall
guy and you're sitting on like the
second row you're gonna get called out i
don't remember what he said but
um
i don't think this is a bad idea
i actually think that going to a comedy
club with six six people
this kind of thing and i know this isn't
the point of the story
but it's a good idea it's definitely an
experience putting people into a
situation that is awkward and seeing if
you can still have a good time and how
they react okay you know what i'm saying
that's true
i'm not saying you want to purposely put
people in an awkward situation basically
on a first date you impersonating the
cop is a version of this because think
about it but you were doing it at jessie
at least this is yeah we're in this
together can we get can we survive this
but here's the thing if if she had been
i i could tell that jesse was into the
fact that i was doing it that i was
making the choice and but she was kind
of embarrassed because she didn't know
how to react but i thought that was cute
and i also thought she likes this but if
a girl would have been like
what are you doing why are you doing
this then that's you're being stupid
it'll be like well you don't want to be
with me because i'm going to be stupid a
lot
i got these glasses i got other things
too yeah
mostly just the glasses you're not into
this
this is not going to work
yeah so i think this is it wasn't a bad
idea for a date but absolutely just
yourself be if weird is you because it's
going to come back to bite you in the
potato face
right if it's but for him
if he didn't know he was stepping into
that it's it's like you can't take up
with hey don't call her potato face you
look like
you look like a mashed potato body which
is probably what
you might have done in that situation
yeah besides i'm gonna be the hero in
this moment so you you look like you're
like a chomp they're making fun of your
date and you just got to sit there and
laugh at her
i mean
yeah i don't you have to do i actually
don't know how to respond in that point
like what
is there a silver bullet here
i don't think there's any reason that in
in the context of a comedy club if a
comedian calls you out you should get
mad at them that's just a bad look
i just think you got it like you got to
show that you can take a joke
yeah
yeah you know
yeah this is this was a test for her
and he just needed to
to analyze it
uh brittany westendorf brittany met a
guy on match.com this is something we
have no experience with online dating
we decided to meet at a cute irish pub
we sit down order drinks and start
talking everything was good until not
even 10 minutes into the date his ex
shows up and start screaming at us she
knew we had met online somehow and was
yelling
match.comdatematch.com day
he quickly threw down money to cover
drinks and tip and we left she followed
me across the street to my car yelling
about him we finished the date at a
different restaurant funny enough the
next man i met on match is now my
husband of six years and we've been
together for over eight years match.com
wow
that's
that's crazy this is like one of those
uh people on the
on the bachelor
where
um
you know uh they the one of the girls
will find out that the other girl was
like and she goes up to the bachelor and
she's like
do you know that um
vanessa
just got out of a relationship
like right before this started
you know like trying to you know
having somebody's ex to deal with who
thankfully i don't i this is not
something i've ever personally
dealt with did you ever did you ever
have with an ex
well
did you have an ex meet a current
girlfriend
surely
i know i know that
i know that jessie met my previous
girlfriend at some point and they were
both like so sweet that it was just
totally fine
a little bit awkward christy met my
accent it was a it was awkward
and but she went to school with jessie
so they were they were acquaintances
yeah right yeah
so it was like she was kind of in the
she was still in the in the mix
wasn't she involved in crew yeah at
carolina yeah and then if we had like
retreats where like we'd all come
together she would be there she'd be
there she'd be there yeah
i hadn't thought about this in a long
time and my ex-girlfriend but i would
high school i would talk
i would talk to her like
friendly but like it was mostly i i
think avoidance but my ex-girlfriend
from high school was also involved in
crusade
remember that
no
who
initials
a jb oh yes
oh yeah yes but but that was earlier
that was like your junior year it wasn't
your senior there was more time so it
was like but she was there the whole
time
oh wow but she wasn't as involved right
well she went to a different school that
was a part of our group okay but no but
she was like no she was there and my
brother's
ex-girlfriend was also at the same
school yeah that your wife was at
halloween like there was like
oh no it's a smile i mean
when we start dating a group of people
and then we all got involved in campus
crusade kind of makes me glad that i
didn't date more people
but
you know you talk about the the analysis
thing with the previous person
that's part of what i miss is that like
we always enjoyed meeting new people and
then
because we would both be meeting a lot
of the same new people throughout our
lives we we'd like develop this skill of
assessing people you know we would come
back and talk about like did you notice
that guy has this weird habit where he
like he grabs his right ear
and he's he sucks on his teeth or you
know and we we would talk about
people like we're just fascinated and we
like to assess people
and first dates are kind of like that
there's this dance of
like you said i'm just going to be
myself if jesse reacted like oh stop
being stupid you're making me feel weird
it's like
that's something you want to learn it's
like you're learning so much so quickly
on first dates it just seems like even
if they don't go well you could have
this perspective that like i would like
to give to my kids it's like you know
what just even if it's not going well
that can be fun because that's mission
accomplished yeah
this is all part of it it's a
reconnaissance mission going both ways
well one of the first things that
one of the first dates
after that outback date
uh that we
i took jesse to baja burrito which i
don't even know if it's still there it
is across the street from nc state's
campus yeah and
it was good it was a casual date it was
we're going to go to baja burrito this
is like before chipotle and like moe's
existed it was the only place that we
knew of that you'd get like a big
burrito and it was crazy that it existed
and we loved it yeah
and
i didn't i his first burrito of i have
there was in college yeah and so having
having a burrito then just walking
around campus
and
she specifically
i remember thinking wow she's really
going after that burrito
okay
and and i say that because she then
later told me
she was like i made a conscious decision
to show you how i could deep throat a
burrito
exactly yet on those amber vision
glasses
no
she she was like
i like to eat
and i like this burrito and i'm going to
eat this burrito aggressively to show
you that this is who i am
and if you can't take me
devouring this burrito graciously in
front of you something tells me that it
was totally good with you yeah but the
thing is is that again
my impression as not one who dates now
but
uh
some people will go on a date and we'll
be like i'm gonna barely eat because i
don't want to send the wrong thing or
i'm gonna order i'm just gonna get just
a salad not because i've already eaten
like christy right because
and so i really appreciated that about
her at the time i was like but i it was
it was notable i was like man like
she got like sour cream on her face
right now and she's not even wiping it
off
that reminds me
um
and christy remembers this too she was
like do you remember we went on our
third day of course the second date was
the group date
where
we might have gone to
applebee's
it could have happened
and that's kind of a lateral move and
again it was chili's it was it was
valentine's night tgi fridays would be a
step down she was like you took me on a
group date you were taking a real slow
nonchalant but you know what that was
fine because i had already had
a date
valentine's day for lunch
so she went out with another dude for
lunch on valentine's day
he brought her flowers was this like
another state guy
uh
yes
i never knew him
you brought her flowers brought a flower
something you would have never i i did
bring her flowers oh it was a group date
but i did bring her flowers so our
second day this is the second date you
brought flowers yeah but it how did this
but how did this become part of the
linked plan this feels way too
valentine's day you know
i had to i had to acknowledge it okay
then third date
i explained this to her i was like
third date you get ribs
because at this point if you got to know
if you can eat ribs in front of the
other person oh but you told her that
yeah and ordered ribs yeah did she get
ribs too uh
i don't know i don't i don't know if she
got ribs
yeah but
b but my point was being getting ribs
being your [ __ ] i'm gonna eat them in
front of you and i mean you know how it
is with me and she was probably noticing
my chewing just like can i get over this
yeah well good that you do
in a restaurant that has sort of like a
low hum of other people talking you
can't quite tell how crazy your chewing
is
it has to be like a fine restaurant
dimly lit quiet but by the time you were
willing to go to a place like that she
was so locked in that it didn't matter
it was too late this is one of the
unintentional things of how your plan
worked yeah if you had to take her to a
fine establishment on the second date
she'd be like good lord it doesn't
matter if it's pudding or ribs it's so
loud i don't know how this happens
uh
ferda
tweeted at us
so i matched with this girl on tinder
and basically we were planning to go to
this fancy dinner you know and so i had
to meet up with her and pick her up
because she didn't have a vehicle at the
time and when i showed up to her house
to knock on the door this old guy who
looked to be in his 50s burst out of the
door in his underwear and proceeded to
try and beat me with a floppy coat
hanger yelling random uninterruptible
phrases and i ran back to my car
thinking i surely had the wrong house
address but to my surprise the girl came
out chasing after him
and had to bring him back inside and
calm him down and after that when we
went on the date she tried to pretend it
didn't happen
which made it even more awkward than it
already was
but yeah now we're married with two kids
that is a crazy first date see that's
the type of stories that i wish i had
you know this one in particular
i'm not sure
i think uninterruptible may have been
unintelligible corrected from
unintelligible but you couldn't
interrupt him that makes sense uh
so i'm assuming now that ferda is
married to this woman that they now know
uh what the situation was but that
particular situation was not revealed
enough
to our discussion so i have to assume
that this man in his 50s
in his underwear
proceeding to try to i mean just if this
is her father
do they have a relationship at this
point is this this is the father we need
a follow-up okay
you gotta you gotta
you gotta pull back the curtain you
gotta let us know
what happened
you can change names if you need to she
tried to pretend it didn't happen
yeah that's
that's strange i think the first thing i
would say when i got in the car is uh
let's talk about the man that just tried
to kill you he's like absolutely feels
this feels like the first topic of
conversation that's the thing about
dates
i'm imagining
is that you build it up so much and like
you want it to go well that it it makes
it worse
you know if you're just like
i
what a papa i say
i is who i is i am who i am that sounds
nothing like that was god popeye
okay
it was god in the old testament well he
does have big forearms right yeah
um you know what i'm saying now when
you're when you get caught up in these
like really manicuring yourself for a
first impression obviously within reason
but like you gotta you gotta you gotta
put yourself out there
and say hey if this doesn't work that's
still mission accomplished and i think
that this is probably a much more common
thing i i think that dating ironically
dating is down in general
uh even though there's so much
with online dating there's so many more
ways to meet people
and you don't have to like oh i'm gonna
go start a conversation with somebody
it's yeah there's so technology is
provided all these ways for people to
connect but i think again i'm just
this is like based on some things i've
heard i think dating in general is down
but
my impression with online dating is that
people for the most part a first sort of
tinder date or a match.com date tends to
be really low key like hey let's just
meet for coffee yeah this is like what
because why are we going to make the
investment of time and money that's
going to go into this if we're going to
meet each other and
we're going to you're going to know in
the first 10 minutes leave them on
if this should continue yeah
um
which i think makes sense yeah it does
it can be a little cold-hearted and but
and then you can schedule like
you know 10 in a day that way i mean
that's a lot of coffees
that's uh but what if one really ends up
working they want it to continue you
cancel the rest of them
yeah
and you tell them that too
i'm sure people have done that they've
got like a 7 p.m and a 9 p.m
scheduled just in case the 7 pm doesn't
go well
and then if it does they cancel at 9 pm
i mean i'm not saying i advise anyone to
do that another thing we missed out on
was like the whole
like
kit first like are you gonna are you
gonna have a good night kiss
like that's not that was never part of
our equation because like there was such
an emphasis on like well if the physical
relationship is something you need to
delay as long as possible
and you know there was lots of benefits
to that but
i mean it's a lot more exciting when
it's like okay is there going to be
some sort of
goodnight kiss
um
is
tweeted at us i went on a date with a
guy who fell asleep at the table 15
minutes in
then woke up ordered himself dinner
without asking me if i wanted anything
and then fell back asleep until he made
me walk him home
turns out he was tired from his date the
previous night oh gosh
wow
i mean it was hardcore
yeah and i i mean
being in a position where it's like okay
you know what i walked this guy home and
i'm not gonna next time i'm not gonna do
that i've got other dates i can apply
what i learned
on this date with this sleepy boy well
maybe he was just being himself though i
mean i don't want to send next messages
here well yeah he would if good for him
for being himself
jesse eating a burrito
just just voraciously is this guy's
falling asleep he's like i'm tired i'm
going to fall asleep good for him 40
years from now if we're still together
and i want to sleep at dinner but you
okay but if you're not into that if you
don't if you if you think that that's
not classy no i think this is it and i
think you need to be able to say
something
it's like you know what next time
something is like seems like
i'm being
i
like taking advantage of is not the
right if i'm being
mistreated here even on like a on a
micro aggression level of they're just
falling asleep in my face somebody calls
you a potato face or calls me potato if
your date calls you potato face
being ready to say
hey you know uh i'm not really feeling
this well link you don't have to say any
in this situation there's a clear
there's a clear path
yeah if somebody falls asleep on a date
just walk just you walk away
that would that would say you leave they
wake up and you're gone i mean this is
ghosting this is simple it is not yes
you're right thank you for submitting
your story and you know what you did you
were the bigger person you walked the
guy home but clearly the correct thing
to do in this yeah if somebody falls
asleep
on a date slip out at first don't pay
the bill if my wife falls asleep on a
date which should probably happen i'm
not walking away we're in a relationship
at this point i'm committed but first
date yeah they fall asleep you're gone
now
if you're in a bad part of town and you
drove them there don't don't abandon
them
but that doesn't seem to be the case i
mean
she walked him home he could have walked
home anyway right
i would say this this is
in the days of uber
right just leave that's these days yeah
jaybird you want to read this one
the date started with skating
and after christy and i met
at a skating social we so sexy we
decided to wander around downtown and
chat now again
i love this kind of date because you
know a movie is not a great first date
because you're just sitting there
looking at a screen but just a nice
casual walk around get to know this is
this is good yeah it takes the pressure
off to not have to stare at each other
the whole time and you also learn things
about a person for instance
continuing on with jay bird's story
that's when they decided to tell me a
story about how their uncle stole their
dad's identity and how their dad was
arrested the night before his wedding
wow we've been dating over a year now
now if i had this kind of story about my
uncle and my dad it would be one of the
first things i pull out
yeah you know you gotta this is good you
gotta have the the memorable
interesting stuff
uh
in fact
i would
i would assume
that you kind of get into you know how
um
if you're like uh explaining yourself in
an interview
and you've got to go to like 10
interviews by the like fifth sixth
interview
come on a job interview the job
interview okay you're saying the same
thing about yourself you've kind of yeah
honed in your presentation yeah i have
to think that there's there's an
equivalency here right when it comes to
dating you get a rhythm to it it's just
like okay what i do here's what i do
with match.com dates
i mean at a coffee shop
and i asked the following three
questions depending on the answers i
share the following two stories like you
have just because it's just
right i mean isn't this the way i think
kind of boring i know but i'm just
saying
this is just how humans work you at
least have a system to fall back on you
know if i was like a prolific dater i'd
have a system this would totally be me
yeah
uh and i think that
it's warranted to some degree
you know yeah and and this guy was like
you know i'm gonna
i'm gonna tell the story about my uncle
and my dad no that's cool it's but
it's not about him though
it could be seen as
deflecting a little bit let me tell you
about my family
yeah takes the focus off of him for a
moment but but you know what it it
worked they've been dating for over a
year
here's one
page tweeted at us
and i don't you know i don't know how
much you thought about this before you
did it but you did it so we're gonna
read it uh i met up with this guy who
was absolutely smitten with me a few
years back he picked me up for dinner in
this new dress i bought and he even
bought a new tie it was all very cute
very formal dude wearing a tie anyways
we had dinner and it was going super
well when we got back to my apartment
things started to get hot and heavy oh
we were still fully clothed and suddenly
right after he pulled my dress straps
off and down partly okay
details
he hesitated and loudly stammered
uh
i need to go change
i looked down
and there was a huge wet spot forming
for reference i was 22 and he was 26.
i was in so much shock that i just let
him leave to change he had an extra pair
of pants handed okay he was prepared for
this
makes you wonder if that happens a lot
to him
after nothing else happened and he never
spoke to me again
i hope he was able to get the stain out
of his khakis
you know what okay paige thanks for
sharing it happens to the best of us
oh yeah would you like to share
um
i had a uh
okay seems like the answer is yes
a hush falls over i don't know okay this
is not quite the same situation and i've
wow i never thought i would share this
but this is what your biscuit's all
about
um
i and
i've never had a situation where it was
just like things were moving in that
direction and then
the gun went off by accident
uh as is the case in this situation
there's a lonely island song about this
what is it
jizz in my bag
yeah right it's a great song um
oh man but
there was a dry humping there was a dry
humping uh
excursion in sweats oh
yeah that that ended in there this is
different but yeah of course the gene
jamming i've talked about this too oh so
you've
yeah you've jizz in your pants while dry
humping
yeah okay so i got you to exit but
that's different than what happened here
and this guy apparently knew there was a
possibility because he has an extra pair
of pants good for him
give always be prepared
it's a good boy scout i mean first of
all i don't know what i i don't think
it's it's of course it's embarrassing
it's embarrassing but but it's but
doesn't change
it as a compliment right yes
because it's just like man like he was
so into into you
that
just the thought of being into you
i think it was more than just the
thought
there was more going on than just
thoughts
what was going on
well they were fully clothed but things
were starting to get hot and heavy
yeah but like it just felt like straps
were being pulled down it was like
things were getting ready to happen well
i don't think there was friction i think
this is fully oh not i think this is not
friction but fiction in his mind well i
mean they're making out there's mouth
friction
yeah but not friction on them
yes yes
you're right that's the point i'm trying
to make point made um
and so yeah but hey you know what
it happens to the best of us because we
consider ourselves the best well so i do
think i i mean i'm actually not what
happened to us but i'm interested to
think to to know do
do women take this as a compliment
and then i do you know there are some
things that um yeah this isn't this
isn't something that you want to be
happening on a regular basis and this
could they should take it as a
compliment they should think it's a
compliment but it also is a sign that
like okay well if we actually begin
making love
then this is not going to be a very long
experience well the second time around
it might be it might be
yeah yeah
you can't
you can't draw a long-term conclusion
from a short-term
explosion
don't get in your own head about this
so no that it is not an indication
of
a lack of prowess or stamina it's a it's
just no but it could be an isolated
incident but that's how he interpreted
it because he never spoke to her again
and that yeah that's sad and i don't
know if because
for vulnerability which is great
for building a relationship if this
happened to me i'm just going to go
ahead and tell you what i would do okay
i'd go to the bathroom i'd change i put
on my amber vision glasses come back
outside i come back out and say excuse
me ma'am there's been an accident
no one is
everyone's okay you're being arrested
for being too hot you know what i'm
saying like yeah you gotta have the
glasses you gotta be ready
you gotta be ready for these or or you
could have a uh a puppet
a guy excuse me a guy who just is in his
pants and then comes out of the bathroom
where the puppet
okay just like the guy who falls asleep
run
leave at that point
oh my goodness
edgar alley poe
uh if you want to stop listening to this
podcast
it that's that was the climax
okay no offense to edgar allen poe but
here we go went bowling hey great first
date
was fine until he started pouting
because i beat him okay a grown-ass 24
year old poutine because i beat him in
bowling later at dinner he ate a
barbecue burger with blue cheese he
asked if i wanted a bite okay he's nice
i declined because i don't care for
barbecue sauce or blue cheese wow he
tipped less than ten percent because
they were busy and service was a little
slow
i left a better tip oh
he walked me to my car and sneak
attacked me with a kiss a blue cheese
kiss all i could taste was blue cheese
and barbecue sauce
i threw up on his shoes
i don't even feel bad about it we never
went on another date wow okay
yeah i think if you're knowing that this
date is not for you
uh well it was a sneak attack kiss so i
can't hold that against you
i mean just maybe maybe don't vomit on
the guy's shoes i mean he's still a
person
i
recently i'm not a person that you want
to date anybody the thing that i'm going
to focus on here is the tipping because
i'm a competitive person and i'm not
saying i would pout if i got beaten
bowling but if you're going to bowl with
me on a first date i am trying to beat
you
just i can't help it i'm a competitive
person i'm gonna be having fun i may
bring my glasses but i'm gonna try to
beat you uh i like blue cheese if she
beats you you're gonna you're gonna have
a hard time with that uh
i think
no i think i would respect a big damn
girl
but
jesse bowled a 36 the first time we ever
bowled together and i actually ended up
making a there was a bowling party uh
barbie or something like that it wasn't
barbie it was a different brand i ended
up
taking the bowling party barbie
and changing it to bowling party jessie
and putting all these quotes about jesse
and it says she can bowl a 36 and gave
it to her as a gift oh
in that case
you gloated yeah she loved it
she's not competitive she wasn't trying
to beat me
but uh the tipping thing i recently
heard somebody say
and this is a very rough paraphrase
do not trust a person
who
treats underpaid service workers poorly
for no reason at all
right so
people
and it was in the context of a waiter
translation if someone is for no reason
at all just kind of an [ __ ] to a
waiter
they're not a good person like i'm not
saying i necessarily agree with that but
i'm saying that was the point with that
that was the point that was the point
that somebody was making i think that i
think that you kind of have to have
you have to have special knowledge
to then come to that conclusion and a
lot of people don't have that they're
just ignorant to the fact that like of i
if you've never waited tables and you've
just because you haven't thought about
that particular type of job doesn't make
you
someone who doesn't have empathy it
doesn't mean that you're a horrible
person i'm getting defensive now because
i'm sure i've
historically undertipped because i have
a fixation with finances it's about me
it's not about them but also i do
reserve the right now
to my tip
reflects the quality of service
but i do tip generously
well but there was a time in my past
when i wasn't thoughtful about it
and it doesn't make me automatically a
horrible person that you shouldn't go
out on a second date with but it might
warrant a gentle conversation okay but
you're talking about two different
things you're talking about two
different things
first of all i have a different
philosophy of tipping
and my wife is like the i mean i'm a
generous tipper it's twenty percent
at least and it and and so if you're a
bad waiter you get twenty percent and if
you're good it goes up from there that's
my you know i don't i'm a i'm a i don't
punish people i'm a i i'm a wealthy
person so it's not this is not a
sacrifice for me to do that right um so
you know but
and when i was
when i was uh not a wealthy person i was
18 and then up from there but that's not
that's what's being talked about here
the thing i'm talking about is you know
the people who
um
are just kind of just short where the
waiter right from the beginning like get
frustrated and they're kind of just an
[ __ ] to a waiter before they've even
really done anything if it's part of a
if the tipping is part of a bigger
package then yes this absolutely can be
an indicator because that's the thing
that i'm talking about and and i was
just thought it was i think it was a
tweet i don't know who tweeted it but i
was like that's an interesting thing
because i've always been like man yeah
like i don't understand it when people
and i've been in groups of people before
and i haven't seen you be an [ __ ] to
a waiter before
but i've been a group of people where i
was like ah this person is
being really short with this person and
treating them like a servant
yeah you know what i'm saying yeah
that is just there to please them and
i'm just like i i get bad vibes and i
just have to believe that that
translates into other other things yeah
throw up live shoes but liking blue
cheese
that's an attribute
that means you're probably a person of
good character okay neppy nut we are
going to read your tweet i had an
impromptu date with someone i met at a
meetup group during the course of the
date he did the following told me he was
missing a testicle due to an accident
okay it happens yeah
apparently didn't have a phone
wallet or car okay yeah yeah it's
when offered to drive him home he tells
me he lives it an hour and a half away
okay
uh
he asked to use my phone to call his mom
to get a ride
leaves a voicemail for his mom and
talked in a baby voice for the whole
thing
yeah it's like i mean
probably the testicle's not his fault
but like there's a preponderance of
evidence here
leaving that one
on the table right
uh didn't even have the right number for
his mom and got a call back from someone
who was pissed that they were calling
gosh
yeah don't call me
so fake
i ended up leaving him at an ihop
but i also made out with him a little
since i felt like an [ __ ] leaking
give him a little nookie for the road
that's not nookie
that's not
what's nooky
intercourse
a look i mean but a little nookie can be
a kid it's just a little intercourse no
okay well i guess we have different
definitions he didn't give him nookie
that's good uh
i didn't hear from him for two weeks
until he emailed me and asked if we
could do it all again so i really
enjoyed the date this to me the evidence
points towards
um
this guy was making a youtube prank
video
it's okay well what come what kind of
things could i say well i'm going to
start with i've got one test yeah you
got to take that into account now you
know are you being you youtube pranked
it's just like how far can i push this
and it's going to be a tick tock rant
how far can i push this and still make
out with a girl
yeah that sounds like a really bad it's
come on well don't make out with
somebody out of guilt let's not do that
yeah i i agree you know you don't have
to do that
you don't have to do that yeah you can't
hold the one testicle against the guy
accidents happen let him do that yeah
and
you got to protect it but based on
all the other actions that he's taken it
he may have
you know it may have been a bonehead
move that ended up resulting in losing a
testicle we don't know wow i mean maybe
maybe we circumvented a world of hurt by
not having more first dates and i'm
certainly grateful for how it ended up
yeah
still got both our testicles
no neither one of them i mean they work
but just not in the same fashion as they
did right you know back in the day um
instead of giving a wreck this week to
shut things down i wanted to acknowledge
that many of you responded to my request
to
share pictures that you recreated with
with large spans of time in between them
just like
uh jesse and locke did when they went to
san francisco
carol
thanks for your golden gate brill has a
golden gate bridge one a lot of san
francisco sites
elizabeth
um
recreated photos
um
that their mom took on a slide
look at that it looks like either that's
a new slide or the slide was painted but
you know what
i'm into it i think good form yeah this
is like keeping keeping the arms in the
right place you get the facial
expressions the same way this is that's
what you got to do that's a real good
one um harrison said a handful of years
ago my sister and i recreated a bunch of
childhood photos for a christmas gift
from my mother that's a great idea
here's one of the better ones
it's like
covered a younger brother in stickers
and and did it again as an adult and
also and capture the same sort of
faded
film process quality yeah really nailed
it
mythical noodle rat
recreated
a trio photo here not as much time had
passed there
but i'll still expect eleven years
have passed well you have an age to do
it yeah you guys haven't changed in 11
years caroline said there's 25 years
between uh these two sibling photos
i love how they're like especially the
dude in the back is really trying to
he's like seething with anger inside for
being in this well but but no they they
got the same both brothers got the same
uh expressions down pretty solid
and then finally uh lisa
i think how i would say that and these
so these are lots of um washington d.c
some photos my husband and i recreated
for my childhood trip to dc 1995 to
2014.
okay that's good
i like it
if you're watching the audio version of
this you're not seeing as much
but you can click on it
it's a fun exercise
yeah
and you know
just to wrap up the the our fears with
like blowing up our own origin story
uh
kirsty tweeted at us today's ear
biscuits was yet another example of us
as mythical beasts being given a glimpse
behind the curtain did some of the
revelations come as a surprise yes but
the fact that rhett link are comfortable
and secure enough in themselves in their
body of work to explode their origin
story is in a strange way reassuring it
highlights the fact that regardless of
how their friendship came into being it
is unbreakable
the initial spark is undoubtedly
important but it takes far more than a
spark to keep a fire burning brightly
i'm glad that you see it that way fire
i was a little nervous after we finished
recording that and then seeing a couple
of tweets early early the day it was
released under the hashtag your biscuits
people were like
shocked and but then i started realizing
that people were
kind of they were shocked but they
weren't they didn't feel deceived and
they weren't mad i didn't see anybody
who was like legitimately upset about it
they were like yeah we get it
um
yeah but thank you for articulating that
it's it's still
it's still just an ear biscuiteer thing
you know this you know the truth yeah
it'll never get out to anyone else so
hashtag gearbiscuits um
let's keep the conversation going we we
appreciate your responses let us know
what your take on first dates are same
including hours same time same place
next week okay
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best